texting title you love them all [ __ ]
you tapped into a good night [ __ ]
[Music]
are you [ __ ] kidding me it's like
grandpa's basement right here look at
this [ __ ] smoke-filled death room
welcome to the church preacher CH
[ __ ] everybody wants to [ __ ]
die but nobody wants to [ __ ] will go to
heaven love me everybody wants to go to
heaven but nobody wants to [ __ ] die
well that changes tonight
[Music]
be polite it's the menu of that today
three women the hospital
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
she gotta may say these bands oh oh [ __ ]
Wednesday night you thought you are the
[ __ ] weeds huh [ __ ] yeah uncle Joey's
here with his [ __ ] hoop Duke beetle
merengue [ __ ] head to throw in heat
tonight [ __ ] we got a [ __ ]
tremendous show tonight but it's not the
show I'm concerned about it's what we'll
consuming tonight tonight we're doing a
[ __ ] trifecta of death you understand
me when you come out to California you
hit me up you go Joey
I want to be part of the trifecta of
debt what's the trifecta of debt you
don't want to know if you're under 18
hang up right the [ __ ] now if get a
place in Ty's tonight if you were
holding something for Friday and
Saturday
or some [ __ ] concert knock it off
you're gonna need it tonight tonight's
your lucky [ __ ] night
[Music]
oh [ __ ] such a lovely place such we got
moon bars okay for starters we got
transmission fluid we're doing the
[ __ ] trifecta
don't worry about who told me nobody
tells me nothing I [ __ ] think about
legit and we got blood stars tonight
dispose of death understand we're gonna
open up a little chocolate booth I'll
spare Li I'll save them for the plane
ride tomorrow start off with your little
chocolate tank listen this is money
right here if you want to see this if
you want to die and come back from that
this is what face sticking the coffin
right here you'll be back quicker than
Jesus [ __ ] three days Jesus [ __ ] fail
I was running for the door are you
[ __ ] kidding me that's what you do
have you been the Voodoo Lounge all that
[ __ ] you're talking the poopoo lounge is
no joke many people have walked through
and many people have ran the [ __ ] out of
here you can smell it tonight the THC is
in the [ __ ] air
[Music]
Oh chip
yummy for your tummy
nine thousand milligrams a hash or what
the [ __ ] is gonna go we got some stars
at that bit slow down
go five apiece [ __ ] party started
[Music]
to watch Li and then [ __ ] take
chocolate last night fake chocolate was
eat
look at him tonight
he's over he's sitting there like huh
like he's about to get raped the
Catholic school but like he's in the
front the [ __ ] prep room you gotta
say it live he's bothering uncle Joey it
pumping [ __ ] that one too
[Music]
[Music]
did I do it anyway I'm happy muhfuckas -
inside we got a great show I'm gonna
good move leaving a good move you're
here what else can i [ __ ] ask you tell
me what else I asked for a lot of people
aren't satisfied with their [ __ ]
lives they want more more more more MORE
and for what for what you can't take the
wit you can't do all these [ __ ]
things I just want to be happy it took
me 40 [ __ ] years to figure that out
that everybody's looking for money
everybody's looking to be a star visit
you know what your goal is to be happy
smoke reefer giggle by yourself that's
the best feeling of the [ __ ] world
what beats there's only one thing
getting [ __ ] the ED moaning you
[ __ ] you know but besides that what
else gives you more satisfaction than
[ __ ] giggling like a little [ __ ]
[ __ ] just gay come on I do it every
[ __ ] day and you know what it's
keeping me [ __ ] alive for 40 years I
walked around angry little [ __ ] you
angry oh what a [ __ ] you angry what are
you angry for you're alive you're eating
you got a wife you got a kid with the
[ __ ] yank before that's why I do this
every night to let you [ __ ]
know listen it don't matter this [ __ ]
that's going on listen it don't matter
take care yourself smoke reefer do
push-ups tell the people that in your
life that matter that you love them
every [ __ ] day even if you got a calm
collected I know I owe you 450 but I
love it now watch I'm different your
life [ __ ] becomes you think I'm
[ __ ] telling stories in it's time for
another boat
she's not out there Esther cuckoo maybe
she stopped she'll be right here in [ __ ]
what else is going on you bad
[ __ ] man
he's just sitting out a smoke another
[ __ ] Lee you got stars in the table
what are you doing you still eating
chocolate that could have been done that
should have been done on the walk how
long is this chocolate take thee we
might beat the other bar just to put you
in check because I know he's gonna dick
around tomorrow
yes whitey hey I see none I saw you move
away from the table no I didn't come
back Hershey bars and not one time that
he flinch eats a piece of chocolate here
you think he's getting raped in the
[ __ ] English make your faces last
night you should have seen him use Eden
but he was truly can look at some
questions I knew there was something
going on every time he'd turn away from
the camera as the cuckoo's of the house
we got two different types of reefer we
got transmission fluid we got everything
you look beautiful as Takuya that's your
natural color as the ghoul was raised
with class she always shows up with
something with skirt on looking
beautiful and she shows up with a
[ __ ] number that's a real woman right
there
oh you little [ __ ] is the ha ha ha
you ain't dick you got nothing as the
coupe shows up looking beautiful and
brings your uncle Joey a [ __ ] number
you understand me
ou cannot beat this this is what it's
all about this is this is the immigrant
mental you [ __ ] Gentiles immigrants
immigrants [ __ ] work harder
and all of you [ __ ] and we
bring [ __ ] cuz we're always worried
we're gonna get deported right we go
everywhere showing up with like good
just like back in the Indian pilgrim
days you gotta show up with corn mashed
potatoes something
oh [ __ ] as the cool as to couch it done
you do Doug Benson show I did I got
getting done with high that fight was
called the savage it's got teeth is [ __ ]
you understand me never Google that
thing Google what thing there's this
condition that some people have teeth
grow out of their back what oh I don't
know what it's called somebody must know
you guys there's this thing is really
fun to Google you can google this thing
all the sudden teeth just [ __ ] show
up unlike your head
like 40 shouldn't be a lot of tea no
girl for that a ton of teeth this [ __ ]
that's nice I call it the end or that
makes a lot of teeth on top of see
somebody find that out Google the two
things it's [ __ ] fun
[Music]
[Music]
we don't [ __ ] around
yes Baku you wanna you want to star with
det beste cool we'll give you a little
star at that 125 there's a new kid in
town [ __ ] you understand me
I've been trying to tell you that for
years nobody wants to listen we need to
start it when we go on half of the time
how many were there what seven you say
got a deal with people you say got a
deal oh [ __ ] I'm happy to see them
saying you weren't doing dick with your
life you were sitting there suicidal
thinking about pulling the Robin
Williams or looking uncle Joey shows up
well that's the cool some weed some
edibles and we still have the
transmission fluid don't forget about
that we still got another chocolate bar
in case things get [ __ ] up in here
[Music]
she had a nasty reputation as a crew
well - oh I told you one beep - looky is
typing I don't I don't see none so stop
[ __ ] typing I can't read what's up
that's the cool that's right youtube.com
slash Joey Diaz let's do this [ __ ] right
now
oh [ __ ] here it comes this is listen
let's say you let's say the [ __ ]
stars with ice cream the chocolate was
the hot fudge now we're going to put the
whipped cream on this [ __ ] this
is when you know it's all over ready
stars a debt this and the chocolate
that's what I show up with constantly
everything else is background [ __ ]
music and don't do none tunkel Joey
don't know you understand we're gonna
split one of these me and leave it's
like a Chinese buffet tonight bring a
little bit of everything transmission
fluid chocolate meshuggenah juice
whatever you got worried understand me
why cuz we [ __ ] over that's why you
didn't get me [ __ ] with too long by non
professionals and amateurs out here
telling you stories they don't not about
me
[Music]
how much responsible oh yeah they're
made by Mexicans
[Music]
Lee thinks I'm talking about wind
training every night he'll even know
what I did last night I spoke aldehyde
but he sent me a joint dipped in
formaldehyde whatever small time I was
[ __ ] up last night though
that's my girl as the cuckoo is with two
periscopes meat is like this is like
Godzilla and the smart monster when they
turned up together you understand me but
I'm happy you're here
don't forget I'm taking a red-eye
tonight Nashville I'll see you on the
[ __ ] is tomorrow night 8 o'clock ready
to rock February 10th
socially unacceptable comas Islands I
like blooms don't forget about me but
for right now let's get the party
started at Nashville because that's all
that [ __ ] matters you understand
tomorrow night stars chocolate [ __ ]
grease oil [ __ ] hot chicken we're
going deep tomorrow night so we'll be
back from ten minutes youtube.com / z /
Joey Diaz youtube.com / sleaze last Joey
Diaz I'll see you guys a little while
you know I love you on my heart have a
good night enjoy the podcast and stay
black and beautiful right uncle Joey
loves your mother [ __ ] with all my
heart I'll see you in Nashville